can anyone get to 270 if you were to
have this kind of this kind of margin in
the real in the real situation let's not
forget Robert F Kennedy Jr Kennedy
Kennedy the name which is most
synonymous with the Democrat Party more
than any other name he left the
Democrats because of the radicalism uh
and I saw this video over the weekend
and I thought this was really
interesting if you are frustrated if
you're looking at the election right now
and you're going boy I really don't like
Joe Biden and I don't even think he's in
charge and I can see all the problems
has kind of over the Trump thing don't
really like that don't like all the
drama he's not even campaigning won't
debate I've kind of had it with that is
there another choice if the if these are
the two we're left with right if the
disantis thing just doesn't work out if
these are the two we we are left with is
there another Choice well RFK actually
mapped out uh a possibility and what his
shot could be these are Battleground
States among young people voters 18 to
29 and this is a combination of the main
Battleground States Arizona Georgia
Michigan Nevada P Pennsylvania Wisconsin
um Trump at 29 Biden at 30 you are at
34% and then voters 30 to to 44 years
old you beat Trump and Biden at 31% but
let me ask you this you have to have 270
electoral votes can anyone get to 270 if
you were to have this kind of this kind
of margin in the real in the real
situation we're very confident that
we're going to get to 270 votes as you
point out
President Biden president Trump get on
the ballot for free they're going to
force us to spend $15 million to get on
the ballot I only need 34 points to win
the election because and technically I
could win with 34 points if the other
two got 33 and winner take all and
that's how I'm going to I have 10 months
to take 4.5 percentage points from both
candidates and we're very confident that
I'm going to do that okay as you guys
know first off I fully put it out there
it is a very very long shot that a guy
like RFK and an independent could win
even despite his name and everything
else you also know that I have some
political disagreements with him he was
for the affirmative action uh he's for
he is for affirmative action he was
against the Supreme Court reversing it
we got into it we discussed it on the
show he's definitely more big government
than I am but I know this guy really
loves America I also saw an interview
with him a couple days ago talking about
all of his libertarian beliefs like he
he is a good decent American that wants
to get us past all of the s um so maybe
there is some other way I think that a
whole bunch of people if you just look
at those numbers right there if you just
look at those numbers basically people
under 44 like him just as much as they
like those other guys people don't like
the choices that we
have